today's topic so the trend of you know
like making videos to [ __ ] on people to
like cloud chase is a thing and so I
heard that there's some young men who
have made a video about me being a
narcissist you was right
apparently were cloud chasing so when
she does commentary on everybody else
it's not cloud chasing when Charlemagne
her good friend literally makes his
whole living by talking about the people
and we're cloud chasing so what makes
you that we cloud chases and the number
of fans that we have so we would have a
number a higher number of subscribers
and wouldn't be cloud chasing what is it
what makes it at its cloud and I
hopefully with this type of conversation
that we're having on this podcast today
and I talked about it on my social media
helps you shine a light on like oh
that's where narcissus looks like or
like am I being a narcissist because
this girl called this out for wasting
our time because we made a 10 minute
video about narcissism and he just
included her but she makes a one and a
half hour podcast just talking about
narcissism but more cloud chasing it's a
time to make a video about something
that is not what it is
instead of using that time to make a
video that can actually be helpful
making a video that is you know
educating folks on Rodney Reed who you
know if you're taking time to make
videos simply trying to demean people
who are clearly out here trying to
uplift people again complimenting
yourself I'm clearly trying to uplift
people were you trying to uplift people
when you were calling tyreese's
narcissist were you trying to uplift
people when you called that Kanye West
100 times not to say that your criticism
of him is it accurate my whole point is
that uplifting people so you remember
how I told you this girl's got a pattern
what do you call say something new I
think we're not even gonna acknowledge
that individual cuz he did that so that
you get acknowledged no but know that I
have looked out for him I'm good in my
in my karma my karma is good actually do
you see her pattern she disregards all
criticisms and then always says we're
not we're not gonna discuss that no I'm
good sounds sounds like yes sounds like
Donelson to me you find yourself in
these moments where you have to make
sure that you're not coming across that
way yeah yeah and and so the way to me
to do that is to make sure that you are
being conscious of someone else's
feelings you're leaving space for
critique from someone else because that
is another red flag they cannot be
critiqued no yeah your own co-worker
says you're a disrespectful person and
you dismiss them as cloud chasers when
without you leaving space instead of
using that time to make a video that can
actually be helpful you know educating
folks on Rodney Reed who has now of
course spread across the internet as an
as a man who is scheduled to be
literally murdered by the state of Texas
on November 20th for a crime that there
seems to be insurmountable evidence
proving his innocence make a video about
that make a video about that why can't
we do both you get to post hundreds of
hours of footage of you and your stupid
cat
do I ever say why don't you make a video
about that why don't you make a video
about that but if we make one video
covering how destructive narcissism can
be or wasting our time why don't you
about that you don't make a video about
that here's sounding like a seal shut
the [ __ ] up something like a seal a
narcissist is somebody who is willing to
disrupt your space in order to preserve
their yep
a security guard put hands on me and I
can't put hands back because for obvious
reasons so I would love to but Marissa
security guard but I can't you're not
gonna lose your shoes tonight boo boo
and then you want to go there even if
you're not wanted if someone tell me we
don't want you at the club I don't care
for disrespect umming back I don't care
if it's the birth of black baby Jesus I
am NOT attending I was like you know to
be honest I feel like you're unaware of
the way that you
behave and like your the way that you
spoke to me was very abusive and he was
like you are bugging you are wiling I
that is that's taking things too far
gaslighting that is the definition of
gasoline Wow
[Music]
isn't that the definition of what you do
to literally everybody who criticizes
you because the hallmark of a narcissist
is that they don't think there's
anything wrong you can't change what you
don't yeah you was right when Amanda was
kicked out of the party one thing that
she said that I thought was really
interesting
and as a way woman telling me I can't go
in
a white woman is telling me I came and
it was a white woman I mean Kiara
she still got out enlight and tried to
manipulate the narrative so that you
guys would get mad and be like I can't
believe a white woman stopped her from
getting you to a black any party do you
see how much of a narcissist and a
manipulator she is make it a race thing
when it's not a race thing it's not a
race thing they don't like you yeah I
just think it's ironic that someone who
built her career off of doing social
commentary off of you know challenging
Caitlyn Jenner's idea can't handle the
fact that somebody challenges her ideas
in her behavior they've had a lot of
people that Lahti worth saying that yeah
you know what it's what happens when
that's how black men react when they see
a strong black woman no no when
someone's a piece of [ __ ] it's a
difference I mean you don't see us talk
about Michelle Obama in the same way she
has strong black woman you see me
talking about Oprah like that nope she
could do what she wants let's go down
the list with what Nina Simone Nina
Simone all of them we could do every
Angelou right all kinds of Erykah Badu
Beyonce there's kyleannie of black women
light-skinned black women who are
allowed to talk in these spaces and have
nobody thrown any kind of shaded but the
moment it's Amanda SEALs
all of a sudden misogyny is involved no
listen not every criticism that's levied
against you is a result of your skin
color or your gender okay let's say if
I'm a black man and I'm driving over 60
and I get pulled over I'm not gonna be
like blacklivesmatter this and that no I
was breaking the [ __ ] law sometimes
you're just a shitty ass person that's
all it is and it's okay so he said it we
shouldn't we shouldn't keep for toxic
people who treat women and men in our
own communities like garbage right we
shouldn't keep for them just because
they're black women that's not the way
it works because at the end the day your
your caping for somebody who treats
other black women terribly yeah you
could look it up yourself but black
women are the ones levy a lot of this
criticism towards her they're the ones
saying a the way she talks to us is
unacceptable she denies a lot of
colorism
she does this she does that it's not us
living this criticism so don't do
everything in function of someone's
gender or race it's not always about
that
[Music]
if you don't like me I don't care am I
being in our system and I in our system
you was right
if you guys aren't aware we've just
started something merchandise you guys
been asking you've been hounding goes to
be like yo when y'all go sell some
shirts of [ __ ] so we gotta we are we
want to make sure it was actually really
nice clothing really good quality so we
have you know I'm saying on the original
throwback member though you are a preach
long-sleeve shirts you know I mean those
are gonna be I mean listen we got some
nice artwork done on these shirts and I
said oh no you're a sociopath and which
is we can talk about sociopathy because
there's a fine line there they're all
nice done on a spectrum but he also was
a narcissist but I call them associate
and then within like a month and I said
we need a break I can't talk to you we
need some space he texts me like a month
later hey can we hang out again see this
is what I don't do but it is what you
did last year you were told you couldn't
come to the party
you were deal Scott's plus one plus one
last year Amanda seals went with Jill
Scott to the black Emmy party thrown by
Vanessa she had to go as a plus-one
plus-one she had to motion to security
with Jill Scott and with Jill Scott this
year she was Jesse Williams plus and I
don't give too many small craters you
were told no you slid back in that diem
like hey you up what you did can we
chill what you doing boy I disconnected
when she said people hit her because
she's very light-skinned that's when I
paid for my room and I checked out see
that's what we have a black Twitter just
normal Twitter this lucid that's all
that's black sock right there
listen I pay for my room and I'll check
top mmm I even made my bed
got a big mama [ __ ] I even made my bed I
grabbed my keys my belongings mine it's
mine ask my paddywhacks checked out and
live yeah anyways that's pretty much it
Minh yeah whatever yeah you know what I
like the fact that we're really careful
with how we approach certain topics we
got better with the years I mean it's
all about improvement you know I mean
yeah but I think like we were really
careful not to go about her and talk
about her comedy career when you talk
about her acting that's not the point
my whole point is though it's very easy
yeah with k.michelle video people was
ragging on her for her looks I'm like we
could but that's lowbrow [ __ ] and you
know that's subjective very subjective
and I thought the point yeah I'm not the
best looking [ __ ] out there and
you're not either actually route um I
look all the time I'm like yeah sure
whatever
like it just it doesn't bring anything
to the conversation you know lives
career or whatever hmm you're right
so I mean I think for us we've been
really good at doing that so it helps us
navigate a lot of difficult topics
because then people came back I can't
believe that you was talking about her
you know so we just stay on what matters
yeah and it makes for a better
conversation and better content and it's
hard to criticize is there space for
improvement absolutely yeah I mean you
know
people can be like they big big if you
have improvements let us know sure but
up to now I mean yeah so far so good
well anyways let us know what you think
in the comments below and that's it for
today's video
you was right